I think that most people that are not  nice to other people are broken inside  and are unhappy inside and I think  through you know real psychological work  of therapy real self evaluation really  hitting rock bottom some shock to the  system like taking a year vacation or  getting a divorce or having that  conversation with their father about  about that thing that happened when they  were 11 I mean there's a million things  that I do think can unlock a drain I  think they're the hardest things in the  world to do and I don't take it lightly  I've not been able to do it so easily so  I don't think it's easy but I do think  it's achievable I think it takes an  enormous amount of self-reflection  acceptance and and humility on the part  of the person that's doing the actions  and it takes a complete reset of who  they are from a hardwiring standpoint  and so I would say yes but 99% of people  I don't think will pull it off and I  mean that by the way it's very hard  Oh  [Music]